aufruf zu geduld und solidarität
bundespräsident steinmeier zeigt sich
tief beeindruckt vom kraftakt der
bevölkerung in der korona krise abstand
halten trotz ansturms lange schlangen
heute vor supermärkten und auf dem
wochenmarkt und plötzlich ausgehverbot
in der türkei ohne lange vorwarnungen
müssen die bürger in mehreren städten
übers wochenende zu hause bleiben
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesen karsamstag schön dass sie dabei
sind
normalerweise gibt es eine
fernsehansprache vom bundespräsidenten
nur zu weihnachten doch zu corona zeiten
ist alles anders
und so wendet sich frank walter
steinmeier auch heute zu ostern ans volk
mit wuchtigen worten diese pandemie sei
kein krieg sondern eine prüfung unserer
menschlichkeit und wir allein würden
entscheiden ob wir auch danach eine
gesellschaft sein wollen mit mehr
vertrauen mehr rücksicht und mehr
zuversicht an den körper berichtet es
ist ein appell zur eigenverantwortung
den der bundespräsident zu ostern an das
land richtet frank walter steinmeier
spricht von zuversicht und geduld im
angesicht einer krise die auch am mittag
bei der aufzeichnung im schloss bellevue
sichtbar ist
ich bin tief beeindruckt von dem
kraftakt in unser land in den
vergangenen wochen vollbracht hat noch
ist die gefahr nicht gebannt aber schon
heute können wir sagen jeder von ihnen
hat sein leben radikal geändert jeder
von ihnen hat dadurch menschenleben
gerettet und die politik versucht mit
milliarden-hilfen unternehmen und somit
arbeitsplätze zu retten steinmeier
spricht von einer wegscheide zwischen
solidarität und egoismus und von der
nachhaltigkeit des richtigen weg ist
erinnern wir uns auch nach der krise
noch was unverzichtbare arbeit in der
pflege in der versorgung in den sozialen
berufen in kitas und schulen was sie uns
wirklich wert sein muss
anders als manch anderer staatschef
vergleich der bundespräsident die
pandemie nicht mit einem krieg sondern
sie den ihr anlass zum nachdenken
sie ist eine prüfung unserer
menschlichkeit sie ruft das schlechteste
und das beste in den menschen hervor
zeigen wir einander doch das beste in
uns doch gerade an den feiertagen fällt
das wie hier in berlin vielen schwer
nach wochen der einschränkungen zieht es
einige auch gemeinsam raus die sehnsucht
weckt
normalität wann und wie die
einschränkungen gelockert werden können
darüber entscheiden nicht allein
politiker und experten sondern wir alle
haben das in der hand durch unsere
geduld und unsere disziplin lob und
mahnung zugleich schloss bellevue kommt
zu ostern eine botschaft die das
geleistete honoriert die aber
deutschland auch ein stimmt auf
disziplin und entbehrung die weiter
notwendig sein die ganze neun minuten
lange ansprache des bundespräsidenten
können sie gleich sehen hier im zdf
direkt nach uns und zugleich einen neuen
zdf- heute- app die rund um die uhr
aktuelle nachrichten zur corona krise
bietet dieses jahr ist alles anders hat
der bundespräsident gesagt wir können
nicht wie sonst freunde und familie um
uns scharen eltern und großeltern
umarmen
wie gehen sie damit um hier einige
antworten oster könnte man sie anders
vorstellen unser kinder leben in wien
wir hätten uns gerne besucht da sind
alle so sachen wo familie natürlich sehr
darunter leidet ja es ist sicherlich
sehr schade dass man die menschen jetzt
nicht sehen kann besonders die älteren
angehörigen jetzt nicht sehen kann aber
es gibt eben neue formen der
kommunikation und telefoniert häufiger
und schreibt briefe man schreibt
grußkarten unsere tochter telefoniert im
moment jeden tag mit den omas stunden
lang die hat lesen inzwischen die
märchenbücher über telefon vor und sagen
guten morgen und gute nacht und so
machen wir es eben auch mit anderen
verwandten
also ich bin nicht glücklich über diese
beschränkung aber irgendwo müssen wir
uns jetzt ein paar wochen zusammen
reißen glaube ich bin ganz alleine meine
familie ist in leipzig und da darf ich
nicht hin und ich wäre sehr sehr gerne
bei meinen kindern ja der
kirchenbesucher fehlen mir natürlich
auch aber was muss das monster sahen die
hamburg
es ist traurig denn sonst sind immer
alle zu uns im garten gekommen haben
ostereier gesucht und so die kleinen und
jetzt kommt keiner wie lange das noch
anhält hängt entscheidend von der
ausbreitung des virus ab schauen wir auf
die zahlen stand 8 10 uhr 30
sind laut johns hopkins universität in
deutschland mehr als 122.000 infektionen
durch tests bestätigt gut 3400 mehr als
gestern um diese zeit davon sind
inzwischen mehr als 53.000 menschen
genesen 2736 starten aktuell verlangsamt
sich die ausbreitung weiter anfang märz
hatte sich die zahl der erkrankten noch
alle zwei tage verdoppelt nun erst alle
17,4 tage die verdopplung zeit ist ein
kriterium dafür ob die bundesregierung
die beschränkungen lockert im moment
haben viele gewerbetreibende keine
kunden mehr aber auch therapeuten und
zahnärzte klagen dass kaum noch jemand
in die praxis kommt gesundheitsminister
sparen hat jetzt finanzielle hilfe
angekündigt dem redaktions netzwerk
deutschland sagte er
um gut funktionierende strukturen zu
erhalten werde man verluste abfedern und
liquidität sichern
von den neuen zuschüssen sollen auch
eltern kind kliniken profitieren
und auch bei vielen verbrauchern ist das
geld knapper geworden immer öfter können
zahlungen für kredite nicht mehr
geleistet werden
nach angaben des sparkassen- und
giroverbands setzen allein die
sparkassen zins und tilgungsleistungen
von 80.000 kreditnehmern auszahlungen
werden bis ende juli gestundet wenn
bankkunden nachweislich durch die korona
krise in eine notlage geraten sind
einkaufen an ostersamstag war noch nie
was für eilige aber in diesem jahr
mussten die kunden richtig viel zeit
mitbringen vor bau und supermärkten von
nord nach süd hieß es erstmal mit
sicherheitsabstand draußen vor der tür
anstehen und drinnen hatten die helfer
alle hände voll zu tun die ware wieder
aufzufüllen
ganz ehrlich auch die situation auf den
wochenmärkten es ist viel los aber
wartezeiten und abstandsregeln werden
mit geduld hingenommen heike kruse
berichtet
von oben sieht eigentlich alles aus wie
immer doch der kieler wochenmarkt hat
nun weniger stände auf mehr fläche
unbedingt abstand halten in der praxis
nicht immer leicht zumal ist trotz
reduzierter stand fast ein drittel mehr
kunden gibt kritik an längeren
warteschlangen übt heute aber niemand
eines hilft bei den absteigern ist gut
es gibt uns und den kunden ja auch eine
sicherheit und gerade am anfang mussten
wir ja auch gar nicht was auf uns
zukommt gerade in einkaufsläden kann man
diesen abstand einfach schlecht
einheiten aber es kann jetzt nicht die
nächsten zwei jahre so weitergehen ich
finde es in ordnung die bevölkerung soll
geschützt werden und man kann mal gucken
wie sich das entwickelt ähnlich die
stimmung beim oster einkauf auf einem
hamburger markt konsequente abstands
waren bei den kunden leichte melancholie
bei manchem händler
ich muss ja die distanz bewahren also
ich hier gerne auf den menschen zu das
dann schon bisher mit angezogener
handbremse aber man weiß ja wofür man es
macht und hat ja irgendwie ziel vor
augen dass man dann vielleicht
irgendwann mit lockerung rechnen kann in
kiel lässt die stadt noch schärfere
maßnahmen nun gibt es einen imbiss
verbot für die wochenmärkte damit alle
nach dem einkauf schnell wieder nach
hause gehen
das kleine café mobil bleibt tapfer
geöffnet kaffeebohnen dürfen ja verkauft
werden
normalerweise samstags ist natürlich am
ausgang ordentlich was los vor allem bei
dem guten wetter wie wir sie momentan
haben jetzt momentan ist es so dass wir
halt nur noch unsere produkte verkaufen
können der verkaufsschlager auf dem
markt sind übrigens blumen ein bisschen
österlicher frühlingsstimmung für
zuhause wo man ja sein soll in corona
zeiten noch länger als deutschland
nämlich seit mehr als vier wochen ist
italien im stillstand alle läden außer
lebensmittelgeschäfte und apotheken sind
zu raus darf nur wer einen triftigen
grund hat und die italiener müssen sich
weiter gedulden ministerpräsident konnte
hat die ausgangs beschränkungen um drei
wochen verlängert bis zum dritten
italien wurde von der korona pandemie
weltweit mit am schwersten getroffen
mehr als 19.000 infizierte starben
bislang
wir schalten live nach oben zu andreas
postel wie erleben sie das land nachdem
jetzt klar ist dass die menschen
mindestens noch drei wochen mehr oder
weniger eingespart sind also hier in der
stadt rom wären normalerweise jetzt zum
osterfest zehntausende pilger und
touristen in der stadt aber rom erlebe
ich hier in diesen tagen leer fast eine
dörfliche atmosphäre die menschen dürfen
nicht raus nur zum einkaufen tragen dann
alle einen mundschutz und über alles
polizei im ganzen land wird gerade jetzt
vor ostern kontrolliert ob diese
ausgangs beschränkungen tatsächlich
eingehalten werden denn je länger es
dauert je schwerer fällt es auch den
menschen sich daran zu halten und die
ungeduld wächst natürlich aber eben vor
einer stunde gab es wieder neue zahlen
in den vergangenen 24 stunden sind
erneut über 600 menschen in italien an
coop 19 gestorben
und deswegen ist die angst groß dass es
vielleicht auch eine zweite welle geben
könnte und dann die entbehrungen der
vergangenen wochen umsonst gewesen sein
könnte deswegen die verlängerung noch
mal jetzt bis anfang mai und alle
italiener müssen durchhalten und mal
sehen ob sie es auch wirklich tun
welches bild gibt die italienische
politik in dieser krise ab das zweite
kabinett von giuseppe konter stand
anfangs auf wackligen füßen
aber während der krise hat sich gerade
premierminister konnte als krisenmanager
viel achtung erworben viel anerkennung
erworben durch seinen transparenten
führungsstil und er hat härte gezeigt um
nicht schwach zu wirken weil der druck
bekommen hat von der rechtsgerichteten
opposition matteo salvini hat jetzt auch
in diesen tagen wieder die regierung
scharf angegriffen gerade bei den
verhandlungen um die eu-beihilfen hätte
sich italien zu sehr unter den esm
schirm begeben und hätte dort
zugeständnisse gemacht giuseppe konnte
hat gestern vehement widersprochen und
hat ebenfalls signalisiert dass er an
den eurobonds an den sogenannten corona
bons festhalten wird so dass auch nach
ostern dieses thema im rahmen europas
nicht vom tisch sein wird die
einschätzung von unserem italien
korrespondenten andreas postel vielen
dank nach oben stellen sie sich vor sie
erfahren freitagabends um 10 dass sie ab
mitternacht ihre wohnung über das
wochenende nicht verlassen dürfen
so ging es gestern abend millionen von
türken ihre regierung hatte bisher auf
größere ausgehverbote verzichtet um die
angeschlagene wirtschaft nicht noch
weiter zu belasten
doch gestern abend verhängte sie völlig
überraschend in 31 städten eine
ausgangssperre
die folge panik japan auto staus in
izmir gerade war die nachricht draußen
strömten tausende gestern nacht auf die
straßen nur zwei stunden hatten sie zeit
seit mitternacht gilt eine zweitägige
ausgangssperre
panikkäufe im vollgepackten supermarkt
in gaziantep nächtliche schlangen vor
den geschäften in istanbul
das kam jetzt sehr spontan wenn wir die
information früher bekommen hätte wäre
es besser gewesen das hat uns jetzt
völlig unvorbereitet erwischt und ihr
seht ja was hier jetzt los ist
per twitter hatte das türkische
innenministerium gestern abend die
maßnahme verkündet in 30 städten dafür
48 stunden niemand auf die straße nur
wenige geschäfte und krankenhäuser
bleiben geöffnet eine solch strikte
ausgangssperre hatte der bürgermeister
von ist dann wohl schon seit langem
gefordert denn hier gibt es die meisten
infektionen
das ist nicht die ausgangssperre die wir
wollten
wir wollten sie für mindestens zwei oder
drei wochen ist der
wissenschaftsausschuss empfohlen hatte
und jetzt diese entscheidung niemand
kennt bislang die details das macht uns
traurig werten die maßnahme vorher
simuliert betten vorgewarnt und jeder
hätte sich darauf vorbereiten können
seit dem morgen sind die straßen in
istanbul und den anderen städten des
landes fast menschenleer
gestern war die opferzahl in der türkei
auf über 1000 tote gestiegen
offenbar wollte die regierung verhindern
dass die menschen bei dem guten wetter
am wochenende aus dem haus gehen ab
montag aber dürfen viele wieder zur
arbeit hier phrase in istanbul diese
plötzliche ausgangssperre wird sehr
unkoordiniert fast chaotisch oder man
fragt sich in der tat warum diese
maßnahme nicht viel früher vorbereitet
und vor allem besser kommuniziert wurde
bislang war es so dass so alle zwei bis
drei tage meistens der präsident in
einer fernsehbotschaft seine
entscheidungen kundgetan hatte und diese
entscheidungen die ihr waren bislang
durchaus auch schärfer als man das was
deutschland gewohnt ist dürfen bürger
über 65 jahre
seit langem schon nicht mehr aus dem
haus risikogruppen auch nicht seit gut
einer woche dürfen auch die jungen unter
20 das haus nicht mehr verlassen die
regierung sagt das gesundheitssystem sei
gut aufgestellt sei gut ausgebauten
verzichtet deswegen auf noch schärfere
sanktionen beschränkt sich auf
punktuelle maßnahmen so durften zum
beispiel am vergangenen wochenende die
menschen nicht am bosporus spazieren
gehen durften nicht in die öffentlichen
parks jetzt noch mal die verschärfung
die ausgangssperre für die großen städte
aber eben auch die ist nur auf 48
stunden beschränkt dankeschön jörg brase
nach istanbul kaum von der epidemie
betroffen war bisher sinken singapur
dachte man ein irrtum denn die behörden
dort vernachlässigten offenbar die
vielen ausländischen arbeitnehmer die
steckten sich besonders häufig an nun
steigt die infektions zahl drastisch
zehntausende gastarbeiter stehen jetzt
unter quarantäne
sie kamen in unterkünfte die ähnlich
überfüllt sind wie ihre bisherigen
quartiere
hilfsorganisationen kritisieren so seien
die arbeiter einer größeren
infektionsgefahr ausgesetzt
ganz anderes thema jetzt vor 75 jahren
wurden die konzentrationslager
buchenwald und mittelbau-dora befreit
von häftlingen und einheiten der us
armee
es gibt keine große gedenkveranstaltung
die kann es nicht geben wägen corona ein
stilles gedenken ist aber möglich und es
gibt die thüringer erklärung mit dem
aufruf demokratie und menschenrechte zu
verteidigen melanie haack berichtet 15
uhr 15 zeitpunkt der befreiung des kz
buchenwald gedenken ohne gäste ohne
zeitzeugen erinnern an die gräueltaten
des ns regimes in den
konzentrationslagern buchenwald und
mittelbau-dora die 76.000 menschen nicht
überlebten stehe zwar allein aber wir
wissen und wir sehen es auch an den
grenzen es ist eine ganz große antwort
es sind die menschen da auch wenn sie
nicht hier vor ort mit uns so hinkel
und das ist wirklich die starke
botschaft viele veranstaltungen waren
geplant 42 überlebende wollten kommen
doch wegen der korona pandemie musste
alles abgesagt werden
stattdessen ist ab heute eine website
online mit den reden die gehalten werden
sollten
zudem wurde gemeinsam mit überlebenden
eine thüringer erklärung veröffentlicht
die jeder unterzeichnen kann
darin heißt es menschenrechte demokratie
und freiheit sind trotz der erfahrung
des nationalsozialismus leider
keineswegs selbstverständlich sie müssen
immer wieder neu verteidigt werden dafür
treten wir ein
dieses ganze system des verbrechens der
inhumanität der zerstörung daran müssen
wir die erinnerung wach halten dass er
nie wieder wirklich ein nie wieder ist
auch der holocaust überlebende naftali
first der als kind auf den todesmarsch
nach buchenwald geschickt wurde hat die
erklärung unterzeichnet er wäre gern
gekommen und schickt aus israel eine
videobotschaft an die junge generation
[Musik]
sobald es möglich ist sollen die
gedenkveranstaltungen zusammen mit den
überlebenden nachgeholt werden
es ist ein anderes ostern in diesem jahr
haben es vorhin schon von unserem
korrespondenten gehört auch in rom
zehntausende verfolgen sonst am
karfreitag den traditionellen kreuzweg
am kolosseum
gestern abend betete ihn der papst
stattdessen auf dem fast menschenleeren
petersplatz die texte hatten in diesem
jahr häftlinge und opfer von verbrechen
geschrieben
es ging um ihre erfahrung mit schuld und
leid die prozession erinnert an den
leidensweg von jesu christi vor dessen
hinrichtung am kreuz in diesen zeiten
des abstand haltens bekommt so mancher
popsong eine völlig neue bedeutung denn
sony zum beispiel stehen nicht so nah
bei mir aus den 80ern von the police
jetzt hat sting ex frontmann der band
den titel neu aufgenommen gemeinsam mit
anderen musikern alle von zu hause mit
durchaus innovativen musikinstrumenten
links unten ein sofakissen oben die
schere oder auch ganz rechts unten
einfach schuhe
[Musik]
musik und singen hilft das schöne wetter
auch der ostersonntag look sonnig und
warm später gibt es allerdings auch
einige schauer
mehr dazu nachher von gunther tiersch
zuvor also jetzt gleich sehen sie aber
die ansprache des bundespräsidenten
ich sag nur noch ganz schnell schluss
und wünsche ihnen trotz allem fröhliche
und innige ostern
was machen denn sie machen
[Musik]